I want to get into this breaking story
of a priest monk who accepted Islam he
says one simply can't be a priest and
among publicly and a Muslim privately
somehow a seed was planted he was given
dawah something happened and it
resonated with him so much so that 20
years later it Blossom and continued to
grow he goes on to say as a younger
middle-aged priest my life until this
point was set I was well liked well
educated he says yet my inner
convictions have changed matured but a
seed planted years ago had blossomed
into full blooms this is deep brothers
and sisters how many of us get caught up
of worrying about a position certain
class of people got everything
everything's going right why do you want
to mess it up with Islam it's the truth
and he was sincere his heart was open he
couldn't hold back and he goes on to
send the article there's nothing worthy
of worship except the Creator